more than my own this is what happens
when you take matters into your own
hands
not wanting to wait 18 months for a new
bionic arm for his son Jamie Calum
Miller decided to buy a 3d printer and
build one himself giving Jamie a left
hand for the first time since he was
born does this mean all the gloves it
was from you bidding me up to get but
Fiona knew nothing at all about it
before we bought the 3d printer we
bought a cheap sort of one from China
we built the printer together and then
we learn how to 3d print using YouTube
some of the forums on Facebook and just
sort of uh lenders who went along the
pair of us they came up with the designs
together the brighter and flashier the
better so far Jamie's dad has built him
nine different versions and then like
when I'm going around like hey if I'm
going to a party the light show off like
a lot it look it's not too bright but
it's bright so we rigged up
rigged up to this and just loosely tied
to that Barney comm uses sensors which
are attached to Jamie's arm and to a
laptop when Jamie moves his arm muscles
the fingers open and close Callum's
launched an online campaign to raise
money for equipment upgrades and to help
make Barnack arms more available for
other kids overall I think in lorries
made him more confident within himself
and I think these arms go out to many
kids all across the world and I think
it's that instead of hiding a weird
disability the more happy to show that
they've got one no they've got something
killed to show off Jamie says the new
hand makes him feel like a superhero
that title of course belongs to his dad
you